that's right kids it is oppositeday for
every force in the universe there is an
opposite I of course I'm talking about
the fact that now that I've done my top
10 favorite movies of 2016 it's time to
talk about the top 10 shittiest movies
of 2016 if you haven't seen my top 10
favorite lists yet I put the link below
go check that out sweet before sour
that's my rule of the world and again
some things to know very important
things there are about 15 to 20 movies
that deserve to be on this list and to
shave it down to 10 and those are the
ones I saw yes in 2016 there were quite
a few weekend's rows like yeah know what
I don't feel like watching that movie
gonna take a little for myself sit that
one out no regrets these are the top 10
shittiest movies said I actually saw in
2016 so let's just talk about this vomit
let's get right into it rip it off like
a band-aid folks it'll be over soon
we're starting at this list we're gonna
go right into the fifth wave I was gonna
put Allegiant on here also I didn't know
whether to do the fifth wave or
Allegiant both kind of embody the same
failure and thing so I figure if you
have one shitty young adult monstrosity
on here you can have them all oh my god
how bad was the fifth wave really
there's young adult book to movie
adaptations they just need to die other
than the fact that I barely remember
anything about it what I do remember
about it is boring predictable and just
plain bad so we don't need to talk about
it anymore I'm done let's move on when
the bough breaks the cradle will fall
into my top 10 worst list cuz oh my god
Ginny premise Ginny execution there are
a few movies that come out in a year
where I'm like I should probably just
walk out now save myself some time I
could do my review at this point but
nope I dredge through it this was one of
those times funny thing is the actors in
this movie are better than this movie
they deserve better they should get
better I don't know what stocking full
of lies they were fed to be in this
thing but it didn't work out for anybody
least of all the viewers but hey this is
a newcomer Assassin's Creed the hopes
and dreams of the many were on their
shoulders of Assassin's Creed after
Warcraft was you know alright there were
things I enjoyed on Warcraft spoiler
Warcraft's not on this list this
soundtrack annoyed the [ __ ] out of me
the pacing and the way this [ __ ] out of
me I feel like Michael Fassbender and
Marion Cotillard both had a contract
like all right you're doing Macbeth but
if you do Macbeth you have to sign on to
Assassin's Creed now they both had to
just
drudge through this nonsense assassin's
creed's on this list mainly because it
broke me just as a video game and movie
fan it changed me inside I can no longer
look forward to video game movies I'm
always hoping they'll be good but if
someone asks me is it gonna be good I'm
gonna be like no because I'm going with
the math on this this is like two and a
half decades of them sucking so I guess
we're gonna be here until proven
otherwise
Independence Day was fun yeah it was
right it's brother no oh my god about a
sequel that we didn't need asked for or
now that we've seen it watch
Independence Day resurgence man it's
just it reminds me remember interstellar
when they're watching that ballgame is
he's great bball players who aren't
actually professionals and gentlemen I
was like in my day we had real
ballplayers who are these bums that's
what I felt like watching the cast of
Independence Day resurgence independence
they had memorable charismatic
characters who are these bums Oh Jeff
Goldblum's back does not matter you know
why because the premise is stupid it
sets up for a sequel that God willing
we're never gonna see and that whole
Queen hive mother aliens thing oh my god
if the first two acts leading up to the
last acting and drag this movie into the
mud the last act certainly did another
dream crushed every the second purge
movie and it was cool because they found
their way they found their niche yeah
the purge election-year didn't I guess
that's the biggest bummer about the
purge election-year the purge anarchy it
found what it was it knew what it was it
played up what it was and it was
actually fun for what it was this one
was not why are we here the worst thing
about this movie is it's embarrassing in
its attempt to actually be a relevant
social film that's not you man that one
girl in there though man she almost
makes it worth at the Laugh act but
that's also why it's on this list don't
just don't
the purged anarchy that just ended 5
next up we had the sequel to the purge
election-year meet the blacks who knew
that was a purge movie it was I guess
kind of it's a purge spoof movie anyhow
it's one of those shitty spoof movies
like haunted house this about is bad
it's actually lower on the list and I
thought it would be on the list because
there was a line or two that actually
did make me laugh or what it was
literally a couple lines rest of the
movie was like having glass shoved up my
dick so there is that doesn't make up
for it it's not funny it's awkward
it's boring I wanted to leave funny I
should just stop saying that that's not
special most movies on this list made me
want to leave the only retribution of
watching a movie like this is knowing
that when you make your top 10 worst
list you'll have yet another opportunity
to slam it other than the review next
one on the list I was actually pretty
optimistic for when I heard that Ben Hur
was happening a remake of Ben Hur could
have been a really cool thing but it
wasn't it was sloppy as [ __ ] leading up
there is this scene on a ship that makes
you think it's gonna crawl out like ooh
maybe that first part was just crappy
nope the rest is [ __ ] horrible - and
then it wraps up with fairies and
unicorns no I hear tale that the
original had fairies and unicorns - but
tonally speaking with the original it
actually worked for what the movie was
as a whole this movie didn't really
properly setup fairies and unicorns and
them fairies and unicorns like imagine
gladiator or at the end they all sing
Kumbaya next up is 50 shades of black
which is actually as bad as what it's
spoofing which is 50 shades of grey
there's a part of me like a 10% 3 5 4 -
2 % of my brain I was thinking maybe
this movie will be funny because a
haunted house - made me laugh pretty
hard a couple times I don't know how
these shitty spoof movies keep getting
made like the days of good spoof movies
they're out there they happen to string
of shitty spoof movies I feel like has
been happening for longer and I just
don't for the life of me know why not
that it's not funny it's that it's not
funny and it's awkward
that's even worse I don't like feeling
uncomfortable in the movies this movie
made me do that it's like if you've ever
been to a comedy club and seen a bad
open mic night it's that kind of shitty
awkward I watch them so you don't have
to next up is masterminds which is truly
the worst comedy of the year for me
whatever the bad comedies don't bore me
at least make me laugh masterminds did
not ever make me laugh masterminds was
proof I'm like Kate McKinnon needs to
get her [ __ ] together she has potential
what is she doing with these roles I
have no idea probably doing what Zach
Galifianakis is doing which is thinking
hey maybe this will be the one maybe
this will be the next big thing when I
was watching this movie I literally I
turned I did this slow head turn to the
person next to me just like this
you saw me out of his peripheral he was
like yeah this is bad masterminds would
have been an interesting enough movie
given his based on a true story I guess
any premise is wasted on a shitty comedy
no here we are my friends we made it we
made it through 2016 we've come to the
number one worst experience I had in the
movie theater the director firmly has
stated the reviews are wrong about this
movie but I'm sorry gods of Egypt is
just [ __ ] terrible god this is the
director of the crowd what happened to
him what's he done the concept is neat
enough but when we saw that trailer we
were like and we were right for that
reaction that movie credit where
credit's due at least the trailer didn't
lie the movie was about as shitty as the
trailer made it look I love me some
Egyptian mythology as much as the next
guy man but when you have bad CGI bad
green-screen Gerard Butler's overacting
not saying he's a bad actor I'm saying
when he overacts that dude overact in a
boring slugfest of a quest I mean dude
nothing in this movie worked in fact
this movie might be worth watching with
the right group of friends like Mystery
Science Theater style watch it like
Batman and Robin where you're like it's
so terrible we have to talk [ __ ] [ __ ]
talk cannon fodder that's what this one
is oh and that's it folks you now know
my top 10 favorite movies of 2016 my top
10 the least favorite movies of 2016 the
top 10 dog shits as it were sometimes I
give that t- rating and then I think
about it for a few days I'm like nah
should a dog [ __ ] that up maybe in 2017
I'll be more liberal with the dog [ __ ]
see what blivet you knowthe blivet is
when you pack dog [ __ ] into a sock with
a hole in it and just swing it around
above your head dog [ __ ] everywhere
if the movies suck I mean hopefully I
don't have to it's been quite a year
folks 2017 is right around the corner
we're almost there as always my list is
different than your list I'm sure I'm
sure you have your list though now I'm
gonna ask you what are the top 10 worst
of top 10 shittiest movies of 2016 for
you whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]